>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
Thank you so much for attending
our literacy conference today
here on reading promotion in the
battle to keep people reading.
It's great to see all of you
thanks to our participants
as well as our attendees.
It's my pleasure to introduce
to you the new director
of the Center for the
Book, John Van Oudenaren.
[ Applause ]
>> John Van Oudenaren:
Thank you, Guy.
Welcome to all of you here.
I'm new as you know to
this Center for the Book,
so I' going to be
learning from all of you.
I follow in the illustrious
footsteps of John Cole,
who I believe is here.
And [applause]-- And I
benefited from the help
of Becky Clark [assumed
spelling]
who has been enormously helpful
in this transition period and,
of course, Guy [applause]
who has organized this event.
I like the title.
I don't know who came up with
that but reading promotion
in the battle to
keep people reading,
those of us who worked a
lot with Dr. Billington
over the years, he always
talked about battle plans.
I don't know whether-- I haven't
worked enough with Dr. Hayden,
you know, whether
she uses that phrase,
but Dr. Billington would always
say we need a battle plan
for this and a battle
plan for that.
So if it's a battle to
keep people reading,
one of the things I would think
would be possibly emerging
from this meeting would be
something like a battle plan
or at least elements that
would go into a battle plan.
So it should be a
very interesting day.
This conference is an
outgrowth of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
which are now in their 6th year.
And the Literacy Awards are made
possible by the generous giving
of David Rubenstein, who's
one of the leading patrons
of the Library of Congress.
So we want to acknowledge his
help even though he is not here
this morning.
And we also want to
give special thanks
to the Advisory Board
of Literacy Awards.
They will be meeting
tomorrow, but I think most
of the members are here
this morning as well
and will be participating
today [applause].
I also want to say a few words
to introduce Dawn Stitzel.
Dawn Stitzel is the new program
manager for the Literacy Awards.
And I think a lot of you have
already had some email contact
with her especially the
members of the Advisory Board.
But maybe if Dawn is around
maybe she could say a few words?
[ Applause ]
>> Dawn Stitzel:
Thank you, John.
And it's a pleasure to be here.
I've been recently
given the responsibility
of overseeing the Literacy
Awards program for the Center
for the Book and the
Library of Congress.
I've been on the job
about five weeks.
And so-- So today, I'm
actually here as a guest.
Today's event was planned
by Guy and other folks
at the Center for the Book.
And I'm just sort of soaking it
in and look forward to speaking
with you throughout the day
to kind of think of ways
that we can amplify the impact
of the Literacy Awards
program moving forward.
And I'm just so grateful for
all the help I've received
from the Advisory Board members
who I've had a great deal
of contact with already and
also a special call out to,
excuse me, Becky Clark who's
been fantastic in helping
in the transition of
conveying the information over.
So, again, yeah, reach
out to me [applause].
Please reach out to me
if I don't have a
chance to speak with you.
Again, I really want to talk
about ways and get ideas
for our moving forward.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Van Oudenaren:
Thanks, Dawn.
Well, I think with that, we
can probably get started,
turn it over to Guy who will
be or MC for this morning
and who will do whatever
additional thank yous are
necessary and called
for with regard
to all the people
who've made this happen.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Thanks, John.
Thanks, John.
OK. We're going to get started.
We have a first panel today,
which is going to be moderated
by Lesley Farmer of the Library
of Congress Literacy
Awards Advisory Board.
She's also a professor,
College of Education
at California State University,
standing committee on literacy
in the International Federation
of Library Associations.
Please welcome, Lesley
Farmer who will introduce you
to the rest of the panelists.
[ Applause ]
>> Lesley Farmer: So I'd like
the panelists to come on up now.
Thank you for being here for
helping to spread the word
about literacy and
not only that,
but take really important
action and efforts to make sure
that everyone has the
opportunity to read
and be able then to
improve all of our society.
OK. So we'll have each
our distinguished folks
introduce themselves.
There we go.
So we'll start with Lois Bridges
of just a couple of words
about why you're here.
>> Lois Bridges: Well, It's a
tremendous honor to be here.
Hi everyone, I'm Lois Bridges.
And I'm the VP publisher
of Scholastic Professional.
And I have the deep
honor of serving
on the Literacy Awards program.
>> Loreiene Roy: [Inaudible].
Hello. I'm Loreiene Roy.
I'm a professor at the
School of Information,
University of Texas at Austin.
I'm Anishinabe enrolled on
the White Earth Reservation,
member of the Minnesota
Chipewa Tribe and I'm also
on the Advisory Board.
>> Stephen Krashen:
I'm Steve Krashen.
And I'm kind of depressed
[laughter].
Yesterday on the metro, a young
lady offered me her chair,
her seat.
I'll get over this.
Anyway, I want to explain one
of the things that's on my bio.
It says I have a black
belt in Taekwondo.
It's true, but I
got it on the basis
of the written examination,
so much for literacy.
Yesterday at union station, a
young man hit me up for a dollar
that was OK, and we
had a conversation.
He said the best-- I
didn't tell him what I did,
I didn't tell him why I was
here nothing, the best thing
that happened to him in
prison, the prison library.
Howard-- He said,
You've ever heard
of Howard's Inn [laughter]?
Isn't that wonderful?
We're doing good work.
Let's keep it up [applause].
>> Lesley Farmer: So I suppose
if we're going to battle
with words, we've got a tai chi
expert right here [laughter].
So I really want to take
advantage of this brief time
and understand we are not going
to be doing the full Howard's
Inn or equivalent of a nation
of readers, but at least we want
to just start opening the
windows, the doors in terms
of some of the issues
because that's something
that we should be talking
about all our lives.
So first we kind of like to get
the idea of like what are some
of the facts out there
and fortunately you also
have a wonderful publication
by Scholastic that
gives you, you know,
some of the background
information.
So Lois is going
to just start us
out with getting the framework.
>> Lois Bridges: OK.
Well, on your table as Lesley
said you should see the sixth
edition of the Scholastic' "Kid
and Family Reading Report".
This comes out every other year.
And I'm just going
to highlight a few
of the key findings for you.
Let's see.
Let's automatically go-- I
just want to mention that if
for the sixth edition, we
survey 2,700 families and kids,
it is a nationally
representative sample
and the people that we
interview didn't know
that we were with Scholastic.
And the idea behind this
report really is to try
to understand the attitudes
and the behaviors of families
as they connect with reading.
So the first thing I want
to mention is the critical
importance of choice.
It turns out that choice,
the books that we choose
to read reflect your agency
and identity as a reader.
And I think that all
makes sense to us.
Those of us with rich reading
lives have a clear sense
of the kinds of books
that we like to read,
the authors that we
love, the genres we like.
And that's a big part
of discovering yourself
as a leader, as a young child.
So we were happy to see that
when it comes to reading
for fun, 63% of kids
say they get
to choose their books for fun.
Let me turn to my-- And in
response to the statement--
oops, [inaudible],
lined up with the--
I am more likely to finish
reading a book that I picked
out myself, 88% say yes.
If I get to choose the book
myself I'm more interested in it
and I'm going to
finish reading it.
OK. Just a quick word about the
disparity of books in the home
and Stephen will likely
have different statistics,
it'll be interesting.
Scholastics found that the
average number of books
in the home were 104 but there
are almost twice as many books
in the homes of frequent readers
versus infrequent readers.
And by frequent readers,
I mean kids who are reading
every single day five
to seven days a week, moderate
readers one to four days a week
and infrequent readers
less than a day a week.
So you can see that-- oh
and one thing I wanted
to mention is how did the books
get in the home to begin with?
And the number one reason is
because kids ask for the books.
So you can see that if
you're a frequent reader,
if you have a sense of yourself
as a reader you know what books
to ask your parents for.
But and this of course
as Stephen will have lots
of information about this,
if you have the means
to purchase the books,
or you have access
to a public library that's
open, it's easier for you
to bring those books
into your home.
So again, sorry, got wind up,
reading frequency
is largely steady.
There's a slight drop
in frequent readers
from 2010 to 2016.
That's good news.
We here so much about how
kids no longer like to read.
And that's not what
we found at all.
In 2010, maybe 37% of
kids thought that reading
for fun was very important.
It did drop slightly to
32% but for the most part,
kids are reading
and enjoy reading.
What about kids use on
the importance of reading.
Again, it's holding steady.
In fact it even went
up a bit in 2010,
only 50% thought
it was important
and 2016 that went up to 55%.
So that' good.
And I will say that we are
keeping our eye on younger teens
because we did notice that
in terms of their interest
in reading books for fun,
there has been a drop.
In 2010, 61% enjoyed
reading books for fun.
And that dropped to 50% in 2016.
So we're going to keep our eye--
we're actually in a process
right now putting together
another report.
And that's a group we really
want to check in with.
OK. Now, this is
something interesting.
Fifty-seven percent
of kids, age six to 17
who are infrequent readers
say it's hard for them
to find books they like to read.
And that makes sense
if you don't read,
you don't necessarily--
you haven't necessarily
established an identity
as a reader.
And so, you-- you know, it's
hard for you to find books
that you like to read.
And I'm reminded of a quote I
like a lot from James Paterson.
You may recognized him as--
actually, I think he
is the number one--
he has more books on the New
York Times' Best Seller list
than any other author ever.
And he said that
there is no such thing
as a kid who hates reading.
There are kids who love
to read and there are kids
who just haven't found
the right book yet.
And so, it's our responsibility
to help kids find
the right books.
And one quick little
story, Annie Ward,
assistant superintendent of
Mamaroneck School District,
which is just north of New
York City is doing something
so fabulous.
I just have to tell
real quickly.
How many of you are
familiar with Stitch Fix?
Does anyone in here heard that?
You fill out a profile of
the kinds of clothes you
like to read and then they put
together a custom box for you.
Well, in Mamaroneck district,
the kids are filling out list
of the kinds of books they
like to read and working
with the librarian, volunteers
are putting together custom,
I could almost cry,
custom book boxes that show
up at the kid's house.
Can you imagine how
amazing that is?
So those kids are going to begin
to regard themselves as readers.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, so-- but this is
interesting parents even though
kids know that it's hard
for them to find books,
parents haven't quite
caught up with that.
Forty-one percent of
all kids said it is hard
to find books to read.
Only 29% of parents
seem to realize that.
So that's what we need
to pay more attention to.
And then just quick
update on Reading Aloud
because that's really
how it all begins, right,
really good news
about Reading Aloud.
Five quick points, first of
all, more parents are beginning
to read to kids from
the moment of birth.
So that's gone up in just--
since 2014 from 30% of parents
who are doing that, now 40% are.
Also they're reading everyday
of the week, not just once
in a while but everyday
of the week.
And they're reading more books,
not just one book
that multiple copies.
Now we do find that as kids
get older, usually age five
or age eight, parents, you know,
the kids are reading themselves,
so parents think they don't
need to read to them anymore,
so it tends to diminish.
But the good news is
that it's going on--
oh, and choice as we
talked about choice,
right from the very beginning,
little guys are getting
to choose their own books.
So that's good.
And the word on reading aloud,
why do people like to do it,
because it is an absolutely
exquisite way to spend time
with your child and
it's just such great fun
to share books that you love.
And then one last slide
on this summer slide
and I'm sure Stephen has
information about that.
But we found that on average
of kids who are reading
about eight books a year, I mean
eight books over the summer,
excuse me, but it really
depends on your means.
So kids from families where they
have less may not be reading
books at all over the
summer, 21% no books at all.
If you come from
a family of means,
then only 8% are
not reading books.
So income level makes
a huge difference.
And I just can't with this
sharing one beautiful quote
from a parents in Texas.
She said, "You're never alone
if you have a good book.
A good story, fiction
or nonfiction,
can open up the imagination
for problem solving
and critical thinking,
or just for working
through the tough spots in life.
A truly good story sucks you in,
and opens up a whole new world."
>> Lesley Farmer: Great.
Thank you so much.
>> Lois Bridges: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Lesley Farmer: So know
there's also some great research
that Dr. Krashen has,
himself, you know,
conducted as well
as synthesized.
And if you didn't have a chance
to get his three-page synthesis
up at the break,
you can do that.
So there's a lot
of facts out there.
And now we want to
tell the story
of why we have this
particular reading habits
and how we can improve
that situation.
And it can be as simple
as students that--
and young people not even
understanding the term reading.
If they think that reading means
just, you know, the textbook
and a basal one, you
can see why, you know,
some students may say,
I don't like to read
or I'm not a reader
where, you know,
they haven't really been
told that book is, hey,
reading is everywhere, it's
your billboard, it's your menu,
it's your game and instructions.
So just reconceptualizing,
reading is a really good start
but again, Dr. Krashen
has lots of info.
So we're going to be doing as
to kind of a whip between him
and Dr. Roy in terms of what's
one factor in this situation
and how do we address it.
So, Dr. Krashen, you can start.
>> Stephen Krashen: OK.
Michael and Greg, could
you guys do me a favor?
One per customer, three sheets.
Pass it around.
Right there.
Thank you.
Earn your salary, OK?
Good. OK. Good.
We're supposed to
talk about one thing.
I have a formula.
And the formula is on
the top of the handout,
which you don't have a copy of.
The big deal is poverty,
poverty, poverty.
Martin Luther King, "We are
likely to find that the problems
of housing and education,
instead of preceding the
elimination of poverty,
will themselves be affected if
poverty is first abolished."
Everything that has happened
since Dr. King said this
in 1967, every last bit
of research supports this
from many, many different
directions.
Poverty means less
access to books.
Less access to books means
not much reading is happening.
The more reading you do,
the more literate you get.
This is my formula.
Thank you very much.
I'll see you next-- oh,
let me give you the rest.
Let me do the first part.
Poverty means less
access to books.
People living in poverty
as Lois has reported
from the Scholastic data that
far less access to books--
[ Inaudible ]
-- middle class communities
to poor communities
in Philadelphia.
Poor children have practically
no access to books anywhere.
Good section on libraries,
public libraries
in the middle income schools
were open more evening,
state open longer far
more juvenile books.
Wonderful quote from
Neuman and Celano.
[Inaudible] I'll read aloud,
"Children in middle-income
neighborhoods were likely
to be deluged with books.
However, children from poor
neighborhoods would have
to aggressively and
persistently seek them out."
I'm just giving you a few
examples from a vast literature.
The more access to books
contrary to popular1 opinion,
the more children read.
Oh let's not give them books,
they won't read them anyway.
Well, you've seen what happens
when the new box of books comes
to the fourth grade class,
the children rush
to see what's there.
The research confirms
this, some reading,
children who live closer
to libraries do more
reading over the summer.
I got the date wrong on this,
on your sheet, it says 1985,
it's 1975 and it's the
heroic Barbara Heinz
who did the first study of
this summer slump and is one
of the absolute best studies.
Our study, my former
student Francisco Ramos,
this is our second
best known paper,
our first best known paper which
I'm sure you've read is called
"Arnold's Advantages: How Arnold
Schwarzenegger Acquire English".
And what he said he did
which were two different
things, OK, enough gossip.
Who was it that said, "If you
don't have anything good to say
about someone, sit next to me"?
That was Alice Roosevelt,
Theodore Roosevelt's daughter.
Anyway, Francisco taught in
a school, elementary school
where they're high
poverty, very few books
but there was a public
library close by.
He organized a group of second
and third grade teachers
including himself
and they made one trip
to the library before
the library opened.
The librarians were very
cooperative, get this,
you better sit down and
I'm going to tell you this.
The librarian allowed each
child to take out ten books.
Wow. Isn't this wonderful?
They immediately had
a classroom library.
Three weeks after the visit,
they talked to the kids,
they talked to the parents.
Kids are reading more, 62% said
that parents were very impressed
with the children's increase
in interest in reading.
They have notice improvement
to child's reading,
more time with books and most
important, they ask the parent
to take them back
to the library, OK?
OK. I'm halfway done.
I'll be done by 6:30
at the rate I'm going.
Part three, more
reading, more literacy.
And this has dominated
my life since the 1980s.
Study after study
shows self-selected--
absolutely right,
Scholastic, thank you.
Self selected reading,
narrow reading,
reading that you choose,
that's your taste, OK,
usually includes
a lot of fiction.
I have really gotten more
interested in fiction
over the last few years,
appreciated its impact.
The US government,
their official position,
No Child Left Behind, then other
scenes against children says
that what we want
is more nonfiction.
They never produced any
data but I think I know why.
I'm kind of like Lily
Tomlin these days,
my cynicism is having a hard
time keeping up with the times.
Why do they want nonfiction?
It's easier to test.
And that's where the money is.
That is my suspicion.
But fiction is fantastic
as we will see.
By the way, I was just thinking
as Lois was giving her thing
about self selection, why
you got to do it yourself?
Do you like getting
books as gifts?
I don't. Gifts are
assigned reading.
I never want to read them.
Van, again, has a
paragraph about this.
He says, I walked by my shelf
and there are all these books
that people have given me.
They knew I was in
English Lit major,
so I get a lot of
Jane Austen, OK?
And I see the books staring down
at me, making me feel guilty.
That is good evidence why
reading should be self selected.
Unless it's my son, he really
knows what I should be reading,
no question, I trust him.
I want to give you a couple of
studies which are just a tip
of the iceberg, lots and lots.
A study from the UK, University
of London has been doing
this long-term study looking
at people since they
were infants.
The last time they tested them
was a couple of years ago.
They were 42 years old.
They gave them a test to
vocabulary, native speakers
of English, then
looked at predictors.
The best predictor, of course,
was how much reading
you're doing now.
They statistically
controlled for how they did
on previous questionnaires, how
much reading vocabulary size
when they were 16,
whether they were read to.
Yeah. Those things counted
but that wasn't the cause,
they controlled for all that and
you still got a powerful effect.
When I get to be 42, I'm
going to start reading,
let me tell you, this is great.
He was independent
of their occupation,
their parent's occupation
whether they went to college
or not, it's reading
that counts.
The best predictor,
reading high brow
and middle brow was
a better predictor
than low brow-- than nonfiction.
Here we go, a point for fiction.
A study I co-authored with
my colleague, Beniko Mason
who teaches at University
of Japan.
Her students were engaged in
self selected reading program
and she helped them
find the books et cetera
under the condition that they
take pretest and post-test
on a standardized
examination called the TOEIC.
Here's what she found, for
every hour you read, you gain,
we now think 0.7 points on this
test, which means you can go
from zero to 60 in two years.
You can become a--
from a mediocre level
just about to the top.
If you do it three years,
you've got what they
call academic English.
You've done it.
So sit down with a
nice cup of coffee,
which is also good
for your brain.
Read a book in another language
and you will make
great progress more
than doing test preparation
classes.
OK. That's what a reading does
but it gives you other things.
People who read more know
more about everything.
Of course, they know
more about literature,
they know about history,
science,
they have more practical
knowledge.
This is a research team headed
up by Keith Stanovich
of Michigan.
We have other cases like
this, kids would say,
they only did well in school
because they had
access to books.
The two cases-- I'll just
read you the details on one.
Two cases are both very high
poverty, very difficult times,
they found a source of books.
Here's Elizabeth Murray
who actually was a
subject of a special on TV.
Very poor neighborhood, she
eventually went on the Harvard.
I'll just tell you the story.
Her dad had a very
interesting habit.
He would go the public
libraries all around New York,
New York area, get
a library card,
take out all the books he
could and never return them.
And those days the libraries
weren't connected by computers.
From library after library,
the house was filled
with fugitive books
from all over the city.
Elizabeth said that
when she was in school,
she played hockey
most of the time.
She only went to
school toward the end,
so she could see what was
on the test and she said,
this is how I sneak by
from grade to grade.
Geoffrey Canada, Harvard
children's-- how--
Harlem Children's
Zone, same story.
He got books from a buddy
of his and from his mom,
they were the source and this is
why he said he did OK in school.
So reading gives you better
language, gives you knowledge
and it also gives you what
we call habits of mind.
This is a stuff that's just come
out in the last couple of years,
big article about it
in Scientific American,
I was very happy to see that.
People who read more have
more empathy for others.
Fiction reading is
what does that.
You go through other
people's experiences
and you see the world
for how complex it is.
You don't rush for
simple solutions.
With that in mind, let
me show you a letter
to the editor that I published.
In the Washington Post last
month, I was amazed it got in.
They had article after article
about Donald Trump's spelling.
And they blamed it
on poor proofreading,
two articles in a row.
And one, you know,
they have one--
people said why you're
picking on him, blah, blah.
Well, here's my letter.
My letter says, poor
spelling is indication
of more serious problems.
Mr. Trump's mistakes
reflect problems deeper
than a failure to proofread.
My research shows, poor
spelling is often the result
of not having a reading
habit and those
who read more know a lot more
about history and science.
They have greater empathy
with other and understand
that the world is complex.
Mr. Trump is a perfect
example of a nonreader.
I rest my case.
You're supposed to burst
under wild applause.
I'm sorry, you've missed that.
Come on, give me a break here.
OK [applause].
All right.
I've been writing him
nearly everyday on Twitter,
and Betsy Devos constantly.
It's going nowhere but at
least my followers see it.
To summarize all these
into bigger picture,
I claim poverty means
less access, less access,
less reading and more
reading more literacy.
The last set of studies I'm
going to show you, I think,
are the most important
studies I've ever been part of.
I did-- I was part
of a research team
with my two former students
Syying Lee in Taiwan
and Jeff McQuillan
in the United States.
We looked at predictors
of both the NAEP exam
and the PIRLS exam.
These are standardized test
giving the lots of kids.
And we did what we called
multivariate analysis,
which is [inaudible].
It's called Multiple Regression.
For both of you who remember
you statistics class,
here's what we can do in this.
We can look at the
influence of predictors
as if they're not correlated
as if they're independent
with statistical magic.
On the NAEP examination,
poverty, yes,
high poverty means
lower NAEP scores,
no question, very strong.
If you put into the equation,
access to books, public library
and school library,
the access factor
in the first studies we
did were actually stronger.
Access can make up for
the effective poverty.
You should be staring
open mouth.
OK. This is amazing.
We did the same and then
we replicated our results.
We did the same thing with this
international PIRLS test given
to kids in 40 countries
over the world played
up in the newspapers.
[Inaudible] the results
should be published
in the sports section, all
right, who won, et cetera.
Well, we found the same
results over and over again.
The biggest predictor,
of course, poverty.
If you add a library, a school
library of 500 books, nearly,
as strong as the
effect of poverty.
In other words, it helps
balance the effect.
Kids in high poverty
don't read well
because they don't
have access to books.
You have the school library,
they read a lot better.
We also found in all our studies
that the effect of instruction
of various kinds,
early instruction,
late instruction was
either negative or nothing.
This is what's counted.
Finally, a few more random
facts that support all these.
When you statistically--
When researchers statistically
control for the effect
of poverty, American
test scores are nearly
at the top of the world.
There's nothing wrong
with our teachers.
We can always improve,
we know that.
Nothing wrong with our schools,
it's not unions, it is poverty
and lack of access to books.
So what can we do about this?
Two things.
And I think they're
both wonderful.
The first one is what
Dr. King recommended,
which is not radical right
or left wing communism,
it's common sense, reduce and
eventually eliminate poverty.
This means full employment
at way--
jobs that pay a decent wage
that people can live from.
This is radical.
No, it isn't.
Number two, until that
happens, protect children
from the impact of poverty.
That means three things in my
opinion, at least, number one,
food deprivation,
good breakfast,
good lunch in school and,
of course, espresso machine
in the teacher's
lounge [laughter].
Yes. OK. Number two,
health care.
David Berliner, his studies high
income areas have more school
nurses per child than
low income schools.
You all know this.
And it's not the crazy things,
it's not the exotic things,
it's things like
getting dental care,
making sure that kids have
glasses when they need them.
The ordinary every day stuff.
Number three, invest in school
libraries and school librarians
which independently show
better results for literacy.
Our hero here Keith.
I want to mention two heroes,
one is Keith Curry Lance.
You know who he is?
Check out Keith Curry Lance, OK?
He is-- I call him
the "Golden Boy
of the American School
Library, so with good reason.
He's been doing this
stuff for years
and it's all very
interesting research.
The other hero, commenting on
Read-Aloud is Jim Trelease,
the Read-Aloud handbook.
My-- Let me tell me about
my mom and Jim Trelease, OK?
My mom and I had a
perfect relationship.
Let me tell you, I
am my mother's son,
you know, I love that.
But, I'm my mother's
son, no question.
She thought I was wonderful.
She loved the way
I gave speeches.
She loved my writing.
I had a copy of the
riddle out handbook
in the office and
she borrowed it.
She gave it back to me and
you know what she said?
Stephen, why can't you
write like this [laughter]?
I wish I could.
This guy has done more good
for libraries and reading
than any single person.
And we need to get
people to read his book.
It's still wonderful.
Post script as Lois
mentioned, there is no evidence
for serious decline in reading.
Everybody keeps saying it,
close look at the data.
You see little blips
here and there.
Here's my analysis which
I responded to the feds
on these several times when
they have this, you know,
horrible articles about how
kids aren't reading anymore,
et cetera.
Here's a comparison.
One of many we've done comparing
in 1946 report and a 2010 report
on how many minutes a
day kids are reading.
Kids are reading, people
are reading the same number
of books, minutes per day of
reading as they did in 1945.
Fewer magazines and newspapers
everybody knows this, OK,
but more websites which we now
have, total just about the same.
There has been no serious
decline in reading.
The problem is poverty.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Loreiene Roy: [Inaudible].
Hello. So reading across tribal
nations is rather impossible
really to talk about these 560
federally recognized tribes,
a 100 plus tribes recognized
by state governments,
just as difficult,
if not impossible
to generalize about
Indian people.
It's also difficult and not
impossible to take one topic
or issue such as literacy
and describe how
it's being addressed
across hundreds of nations.
That said, let's do it any way.
Reading, let's look at what
traditional knowledge might be.
So, using that as a background
to talk about reading,
what is traditional knowledge?
It's important to first
consider what is learning
in Indian country.
Traditional knowledge
created over time,
passed down over generations,
developed by the community via
living, evolving and growing.
So that within tribal
communities,
learning involves a lifetime
of acquiring knowledge
of indigenous ways.
Indigenous ways are the
traditional life ways
of the original peoples also
called world view and approach
to conducting everyday life,
interaction with others
and philosophical or
religious perspectives.
The heart of efforts
to support learning
and reading is the
complete intersection
between cultural protocols
of indigenous peoples
and professional values
in holding, collecting,
providing access and
using indigenous material
in intellectual content.
Work with tribal nations
should be entered respectfully
and in ways that support
indigenous world view.
And we might ask question such
as with their focus on English
in the printed word, art
libraries, archives and museums
as institution seen
by tribal communities
as agents of colonization.
Is literacy an active
decolonization?
The process of removal of the
results of the colonization
and the return of control to
indigenous peoples can support
for reading, take steps
to rectify any adherence
to colonial practices
and attitudes.
And thus reading material
perpetuate harmful stereotypes
to libraries, for example,
represent formal educational
institutions similar
to boarding schools that
restricted as acceptable forms
of knowledge and
depressed native language
and other cultural expressions?
Note though that in the 10 years
or running a service initiative
with my students, if I can
read, I can do anything,
I never heard a native
parent ask me
to not bring English language
books to their children schools.
We delivered 100,000 new books
over the 10 years
we ran the project.
What do we know about
reading and ending country?
In 1919, there was a study
by the US National Commission
on Libraries and
Information Science
and they found significant
barriers and limited access
to library services by
American-Indians due to both
to cultural differences and lack
of culturally appropriate
resources.
In 2007, just last year,
Dr. Anthony Chow
conducted an evaluation
for the Montana State
Library in their LSTA Program.
And he found that barriers
to library services
for tribal members still exist.
There was little to
know convenient access
to either a public or
tribal college library.
There was little support and
awareness of libraries across--
among tribal members because
their services were not
typically a feature of
their indigenous world view.
No work with tribal
communities, the challenges
to engage adolescent,
children and youth older
within elementary school age.
Chow also found that
racial tension experienced
by tribal members
visiting public libraries
in bordering tribal
territory and the lack
of financial resources for
tribal college librarians
to prioritize early
literacy programing.
What's happening in Indian
country, there are hundreds
of tribal libraries and
archives, they exist in villages
in Alaska, pueblos in New Mexico
and the Everglades, in Florida,
in the Woodlands of Wisconsin,
Minnesota and Michigan.
Reading takes place and is
supported amidst the challenges.
These include tribal community
libraries that might serve
as the public library, school
library, archive records,
museum and language center.
Tribal college libraries are
often the public libraries
of their communities as well.
And they are reading
advocates and champions.
Tribal college librarians
gather to share their stories
for one week, each year
in Bozeman, Montana.
American-Indian Library
Association Members advocate
and meet during the American
Library Association midwinter
meeting and the annual
conference.
And every two years,
a number is drawn
to the International
Indigenous Librarians' Forum,
which we'll note as 20th
anniversary in February 2019
in Auckland [inaudible]
in New Zealand.
We see new support for
reading through the recipients
of funding through the Institute
of Museum and Library Services.
Tribal libraries may receive
basic grants and may compete
for enhancement grants and
deadlines are available
at the imls.gov website.
A few weeks ago, we had learned
that the IMLS will be funding a
one-year planning grant called
Reading Nation, that will
support the following efforts,
the Blackfeet Tribal College
Library in collaboration
with the University of North
Carolina at Greensboro,
Department of Library
and Information Studies
will do a number of things.
They're going to establish
an advisory committee
to help design a study of how
children, youth and families
of the Blackfeet Nation
currently use library services.
They're going to work with
that Advisory Committee
to conduct an environmental scan
to understand the current state
and potential factors
impacting tribal member use
of library services.
And then design a pilot test,
a community assessment process
that identifies the
needs and challenges
that tribal members
face in using public
and community college
libraries with a specific focus
on children and use services.
Our data collection
starts in early July
when the team including Dr.
Anthony Chow from the University
of North Carolina at Greensboro.
Ms. Aaron LaFromboise, Blackfeet
Community College tribal
librarian and Blackfeet tribal
member and myself will meet
in Browning, Montana
during the annual powwow.
We will address this
research question,
how might libraries collaborate
in creating a reading
supportive environment
for Blackfeet children,
youth and their caregivers?
What is the current state
of library services among
Blackfeet Tribal Members both on
and off the reservation?
What are the unique needs
and barriers to access
to library services for tribal
members with an emphasis again
on children, youth and families?
And what are the
potential challenges faced
by public libraries
in understanding
and meeting those needs
in culturally sensitive
and appropriate ways?
We're following a
mix method approach
of qualitative interviews,
focused group,
surveys disseminated by print,
smartphone text and online.
Participants were recruited
using convenience sampling,
collecting data at
the annual powwow,
stratified in purposeful
sampling
and sharing a diverse
stratum of tribal members
and public librarians
and a random sample
of a 100 tribal members living
on or off the reservation.
And we're currently
preparing to communicate
with our Advisory Board
in drafting the data
collection instruments.
We'll have more to
share in a year.
I'm going to close with
introducing just a couple
of cases that illustrate the
impact of writing and reading
and including and not including
in some cases native people.
And there aren't
answers to these cases.
I teach a class for the
University of Texas at Austin
and for the University of Hawaii
at Manoa on access and care
of traditional cultural
knowledge and we use this
as real examples of things
that actually I experienced.
So, imagine you're
adding author's reception
at a conference and you're
asked by nonnative writer
about your endorsement of
their latest children's book.
And the writer ask, tells you
that she went to the reservation
where the book is based
and could not find anyone
who could write the
book as well as she did
and how might you
respond to that question
and which I avoided for
three times around the room.
And then had to face
the author and describe
at least what I thought
of that book.
And you can-- I finally
had to say you're not going
to get a good review
and then that.
So that kind of closed
that conversation.
Let's say your professional
organization is creating a
product as a promotional
calendar, and each month
of the calendar is
going to feature.
And you hope a native
writer and your approach
because you're the
president of that association,
and you will be president.
And your approach is saying
this would be a wonderful thing
for you to advocate during
your year and is going to--
and I said that's great.
Oh, the president--
whoever is asked.
That's great.
And because each page
will feature an author
that you're nominating, a native
writer, a native illustrator.
And months later you get a call
saying, well, they've decided--
the committee decided to go with
Paul Goble whom you remember
as someone who did
received the Caldecott Award
but who wasn't native and
borrowed stories from a tribe.
And you say that's
really too bad
because you can't endorse
the product anymore.
And the product is featured
on your association's graphics
catalogue two months later
in the American Indian
Library Association, find out.
And then the rest becomes
a story that's published
in a handbook.
So, read what happens next.
A friend of yours wants to
write a children's book,
former student and is located
a story from your tribe
in an old anthropological report
and tells you this is going
to be a great honoring
experience for her.
And I asked who is going
to see the process?
And that ends that
conversation as well.
And then a friend describes
visiting a reservation
in Northern Minnesota
where you have a connection
and it's everything that they
expected to see, old cards,
lots of dude, and lots of dogs.
So, these are the source
of things that you face
and hear about, and
they are contemporary.
They happen within our lifetime
and perhaps just last year.
And they illustrate not only
what you need to support,
just general world view of
nonnative and native people,
but the sorts of barriers and
challenges and opportunities
that people have who
worked with native people
and with native children.
And I will say miigwetch,
which is thank you.
Chi-miigwetch.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Lesley Farmer: I have to
understand that Loreiene speaks
from great experience.
You can imagine how lucky the
American Library Association has
been as she has served
as a really effective
president for that.
And I just want to
then thank you.
I mean, this is a really,
you know, great panel.
I have to say that because I've
chose them because, you know,
I know how wonderful they
are and that they don't--
and they speak, you
know, they talk the talk
and they walk the walk.
And we're really privileged
in this room, you know,
to see so many experts
in the field.
And I think we can really draw,
you know, from each other.
I think this is going
to be an excellent day.
We know that we'll be
talking about this, you know,
throughout our journey together.
And I certainly hope that
this is a nice starting point,
you know, for us to
continue that reading journey
and to bring others
along with us.
So again, thank you
for this opportunity
and have a great day of action.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guy Lamolinara: Thanks
again to that wonderful panel.
I learned so much.
And so many notions I had about
reading habits were dispelled,
so thank you for that.
I know we're running a
little late and that's
because we start a little late.
So if it's OK with everyone, I'm
going to start the next panel
and skip the break if that's OK.
Our next panel is reading
promotion, what works,
what doesn't and
opportunities for innovation.
And the moderator of our
panel is Benita Somerfield.
She is a Library of Congress
Literacy Awards Advisory
Board member.
She's former vice chair
Governing Board UNESCO Institute
for Lifelong Learning and she's
the founding executive director
of the Barbara Bush
Foundation for Family Literacy.
Please welcome Benita
Somerfield [applause].
>> Benita Somerfield: Hi.
I'm sorry to deprive
you of your break.
I'm Benita Somerfield.
You got my background.
Thomas Jefferson famously said,
I cannot live without books.
And my former boss, Barbara
Bush, felt exactly the same way.
And she lived with it
and she walked that walk
and she talked that talk.
And yes, I was at the funeral.
Barbara Bush and I founded
the Barbara Bush Foundation
for Literacy together
at the end of 1988.
And I left at the end of 2011
when Barbara Bush
decided she needed to step
down to be with her husband.
And her daughter
and son stepped up
and there was a new
executive director.
So for those of you
who've been asking me, no,
I don't have anything to do
with the current
Barbara Bush Foundation.
A couple of things about what it
means to be a voracious reader.
And I suspect most of the people
in the room are like this.
She didn't just pick
literacy because she had
to have a cause as First Lady.
The woman read all the time.
One of my favorite
stories was the famous rat
in the swimming pool story.
Somebody rigged up
something that she--
she used to swim
laps every morning.
Actually she did
that her whole life.
Somebody rigged up
something for her when she was
in the White House that she
could read while she was doing
laps and somehow who knows, it
was a much less partisan time
so nobody blamed it
on the Democrats.
Somehow a rat got into
the swimming pool.
And as she was reading the
book a rat came dashing by her.
And be a woman that really
didn't do with any nonsense
and hate to be interrupted
when she was reading,
she promptly hold the
rat out of the pool
and that was the end of that.
So our panel is going
to talk about what works
in reading promotion,
not the research.
What works, what doesn't
work, and opportunities
in this current time, in
2018 to promote reading.
And just very briefly, what
I'm going to say is, of course,
what I've seen is that
it's absolutely critical
to have a strong charismatic
leader who leads the charge
that urges people to read.
Now, that doesn't mean it has
to be a serious eat your
piece kind of message.
You have to illustrate
why reading is fun,
why it's necessary to do
your job, why it's necessary
to perform in the democracy,
someone whose voice
can be heard.
And frankly, in this world
in which we're living,
I have seen that we really need
to have leaders,
cultural leaders.
Culture such it is but the
current culture who stand up
and talk about why
read, why do they read.
And I'm talking about rock
stars, baseball players,
basketball players,
football players,
people that will encourage
today's-- not us, we read,
today's youth to read.
Years ago, there was a very
effective campaign called Get
Caught Reading.
I don't know if any of you
are old enough to remember it.
I'm 73 although I know
I look much younger.
And there were posters all over
the country of movie stars,
television stars, everybody.
And this really funny posters
saying get caught reading
and there would be a book.
Can't we have something
like that today
that says get caught reading?
And let me tell you why I
read or why I love books
and have a LeBron
James who, by the way,
is a big literacy supporter.
Talk about why he loves book.
I'm talking about posters.
I'm talking about
billboards, that sort of thing.
And yes, we do need books to
be widely and easily available.
Another program I'm on currently
on the board of is Reach Out
and Read, which is a
pediatric literacy program.
And yes--
[ Applause ]
And this again is outside
the box, outside the schools,
outside the traditional places
where books are given out.
Doctors give books
every well-baby visit
from the time the child is
born up to five years of age
with instruction to the
parent on how to read,
even if the parent
isn't a brilliant reader
to the child, the interaction.
And very often you
find that parents,
particularly parents
whom I come from,
impoverished backgrounds will be
in an impoverished situation
don't understand how important
it is for them to be
reading to their children.
They understand very fast
once they get that first book
and they develop their
own reading habits
and it increases the bond
between parent and child.
So yes, let's make books
available but not just
in all the usual places, let's
reach out and be where families.
Families, by the way,
children go home from school,
their parents are in the house.
They're not living
in orphanages.
So if we just look at fixing
the schools and don't look
at what's going on
between parent and child,
how this is ever going to work?
What have I seen that's failed?
He want to-- Guy wanted
to talk about that.
What I've seen that's
failed is somebody talked
about No Child Left Behind,
it's my ex-boss' son I know.
But that eat your piece
approach to reading,
it's good for you that's
why you should read.
Don't read books with
too many pictures.
Don't read fiction.
Read things that are
definitely going to make you,
you know, stronger, better.
That approach doesn't work.
You've got to make
reading fun and relevant
and all the things they
are reading is as so many
of us here in this room.
OK, enough for me.
We have a wonderful panel here.
I'm going to let each person
introduce-- oops, I know, right.
Actually I wondered about that.
We're not behind.
I was threatening to cut
them all off ruthlessly
at 10 minutes.
But I'm not going to cut you
all off ruthlessly at 10 minutes
because we have until
11 o'clock.
>> A lot of time.
>> Perfect.
We've a lot of time.
Then we're going to
have time for questions
and maybe the previous
panel want to come up
and answer questions too.
OK. So the first person that
we're going to hear from today,
and if you'd introduce
yourself and say what you do,
is Deborah Taylor of the
Enoch Pratt Free Library,
which is a spectacular
institution that I'm sure all
of us have known it for years.
Deborah.
[ Applause ]
>> Deborah Taylor: Hello.
I'm Deborah Taylor, coordinator
of School and Student Services
at the Enoch Pratt Free Library.
And it's my honor to be
with you to talk about some
of the things, some of the
programs that we have success--
that have successfully worked
at the Pratt Library and also
to talk about some things
that we have deemed as not
so successful and that we
are looking to improve.
So with that said, I'll
go to the first slide.
Do I have a clicker?
>> Is there a clicker?
>> Here.
>> Deborah Taylor: I don't
think that's the clicker.
>> That's the clicker?
>> Deborah Taylor:
The green button.
OK. The first program
I want to talk
about is a program called
Family Reading Circles.
And Family Reading Circles
actually started with a request
from the Maryland
Humanities Council that wanted
to do a family reading program.
Kind of designed after what
was a big deal in those days,
which was Oprah's book club.
And what it meant was that
you were bringing books
and food together with families.
And as you can see, this young
lady has abandoned her dinner
in order to examine
the books that we are--
that they were going
to take home.
The Family Reading Circle
program is a six weeks program
that we do in branches,
that we do in schools,
after-school programs.
We've even done this program
in transitional housing.
We have done this program
in community centers.
And so, it's been in
a variety of places.
But the main idea
of the program is
that families come together
once a week for six weeks.
Each week, they get two
high-quality picture books.
We read the books aloud
together and discussed them.
We choose books that have
wonderful family themes,
but we also choose books
that are a lot of fun,
have a lot of wordplay, so
that we not only tell people
that it can be fun
to enjoy reading.
We model it.
One of the great things
about this program is how many
parents didn't have these kinds
of books for themselves.
And how much joy and
delight they take
in finding these books.
You can see one of the
things that we love
about this program
is it attracts dads,
not just moms but attracts dads.
Well, we also encourage grand
mom, we encourage all kinds
of folks to participate.
We-- One big hallmark
of the program is
to celebrate the parents, we
give the trophy to the parents,
we recognize that what it takes
for a parent to come after work
for six weeks to be a
part of a reading program
as the big sacrifice and we
honor them for doing that.
There's a great deal of
interaction between the families
and the children when
they come to the program.
They really enjoy being a part
of that particular activity.
In addition to giving
trophies to the parents,
every family gets a certificate,
one of the slides I don't
have here is at the end
of the program we take a
picture of the family together
and they are placed in a
frame called family readers.
So that's one of the
things that they take away
that they will have to remind
them of this great opportunity
and great experience
they had together.
One of the things that we do
when we have author visits
at the Pratt library
is that we make sure
that the students
go home with books.
As we heard from
the previous panel,
the most important
thing is to have books
and to have access to books.
And we used to get
questions about that,
why are you giving people books?
You should just want to
give them a library card.
One of the things that we
know and one of the things
that I know from being
a voracious reader
and a voracious library
reader is
that when you become a
community of readers or part
of the community of readers you
buy books, you borrow books,
you have books, books
are all around you.
So we want to make sure that we
encourage kids by having books
that they take can
take home themselves.
This particular visit was
with authors, Zetta Elliot.
She came to Baltimore, she
did a number of programs
and our schools and this-- on
these tables are goodie bags
that the kids are going to
take with them after her visit.
When we started doing increasing
author visits for kids,
Dr. Carla Hayden
was our director.
And when we would propose
author visit, she said,
where are the kids that going
to get the author books,
how are they going to get their
books signed, everybody who goes
to hear an author
gets a book signed.
What are you going
to do about that?
So we had to find the
money to make sure
that we could make sure those
kids got their books signed they
had the full experience.
This is author Sharon Flake,
we work in partnership with one
of our-- there's
a special project
in Baltimore called
Weinberg Project.
And these are renovated
school libraries.
And we have a partnership
with them so that
when we bring authors to town,
we go into those schools.
Despite the fact that those
schools have brand new school
libraries, lots of
technology, great collection,
a full-time librarian
they don't have
as much opportunity
for author visits.
So that's something that we
do with them, so we make sure
that we take our authors
to visit those schools.
Wes Moore who was a prominent,
was a prominent Baltimorean I
think he's gone to New York now
but every year he would
come to the Pratt library
and he would talk to
the kids about service.
Well, you know, he has
also written books.
So we, we would bring
students into the library,
we go out to the
library to promote books,
out of the library
to promote books
and we bring students
in to the library.
And these students had all come
from various schools
throughout the city
that has service
learning project
because that was the
big focus of his.
And they had an opportunity to
meet with him to get their books
and to get books signed.
One of the things
that hasn't worked
for us has been too much
passive programming for parents.
One of the-- We showed you the
positive that one of things
that really worked well
in our Weinberg school libraries
bringing the authors in,
having them engage
with students,
students getting
books to take home.
Well, we have small collections
in each of those schools
and we call them the Pratt
libraries parents place.
And we have wonderful
collections of how
to help your child in school
how to read to your child.
All those kinds of things
but the passive displays
for many parents don't
work as well as something
that is much more engaging.
So we are already taking
steps to make the--
in our Pratt library parents
place less of a place with books
and more of a programatic
engagement for parents,
so that they really can have
an opportunity to interact
with our staff and to
get those skills rather
than just buying books
about those skills
and making them available.
And that's the end
of my presentation.
[ Applause ]
>> Benita Somerfield:
That was terrific.
Thank you.
Our next presentation will
be from Allister Chang from--
who is the CEO of
libraries without borders
and he won the international
prize of our competition
at the Library of Congress
Literacy Awards program.
And I'm not sure
of the international
community so we picked him.
I don't know.
So I'm doubly delighted
to see him here today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Allister Chang: All right.
Hello everybody.
Thanks for having all of us,
Library of Congress and everyone
at the Center for the Book.
This is exciting.
So I've got a lot to share
and I'll try not to
talk until 11:45.
So who are we?
Libraries Without Borders is
a nonprofit that's focusing
on expanding access to
information particularly
in the most vulnerable
communities.
And I'll read the statement
because we've just hashed this
out and there's always a tension
between how we translate this
from French to English.
So any advice you have is great.
We believe that information
and education empower people
and give them the ability
to make enlightened choices
for a better feature.
To achieve that goal,
we built bridges
between the information
society which is us and those
who are excluded from it.
And our scope of intervention
since 2007 has been classified,
I think, in three pillars.
We've been really thinking
about humanitarian contexts,
places where-- that have
suffered from natural
or political disasters.
We've been focusing on
education and literacy
and also using our
library spaces
for entrepreneurship programs.
So the last time I had an
opportunity to speak here,
we were really in the sort of
focusing on our flagship program
which is called the Ideas Box.
And this is something that
we built learning from work
that we had done in Haiti
after the earthquake.
One of the biggest challenges
that we had was really
in the supply chain, all right,
books getting wet
during transportation,
not having storage or security
when it arrives to a place
that is just suffered
from a natural disaster
or to a refugee camp in
the African great lakes.
So we built this with support
from Philippe Starck's
design team,
something that could be easily
deployed in these contexts,
something that could be fit
on to standard transportation
pallets waterproof during
transportation unfolds
into these modules
that eventually becomes
a full size media center.
With the support from the
international literacy award,
we've been able to grow this
out now to, we've gotten now
over a hundred around in
the world and reaching
over a million people and with
over 2,800 different kinds
of curated content that we
customized for each context,
the sort of flagship
program has been in Burundi
and refugee camps where
partnered with UNHCR.
But we've also done programs,
last year our largest
program was in Columbia,
it's part of the peace building
initiatives with the ministry
of culture and the
national library.
And coming up we'll be having a
few ideas boxes in Puerto Rico
as part of the disaster
relief efforts there thinking
about how informal education can
support the other organizations
with-- working with the kids
that are still not
back in school.
Our goal is to have many, many
more of these out in the field
to support our local partners
and, you know, I think for all
of you here who are perspective
implementing partners,
we'd love to talk more
with you about this,
how can the Ideas Box
potentially support your efforts
in these tough contexts.
But what I really want to
talk with you about today
which we haven't-- I
haven't gotten a chance
to share here in--
at the Library yet is
our new initiative.
And this will be
more of a story.
So in 2015, we had the Ideas Box
in New York in the South Bronx
where we were working with
the New York Public Library
to create pop up
libraries around the city.
And we had an ethnographer
from NYU follow us
for six months thinking
through and trying
to explore what are some of the
challenges that families have
with accessing library programs.
So we setup the Ideas
Box in public parks,
lobbies of low income housing,
legal aid waiting offices,
hospitals, barbershops, street
corner, subway stations.
And one of the things
that we were finding
when we were interviewing
families was
that there's a very
big difference
between the availability
of programs and resources
and the accessibility
of those programs.
And one of the, one
of the main barriers
that we found was really
a scheduling barrier
in terms of participation.
Offering a literacy program
that meets 6 p.m. every
Tuesday is really, really tough
for families that rely on
service industry jobs, right.
You can't afford to miss
a shift, you miss one
of the classes, you're
embarrassed to go back,
one of the main reasons why a
lot of the families we talked
to were not able to bring
their kids or for themselves
to participate in, not only
library programs but a lot
of literacy opportunities.
But this raises a huge
challenge, right, because those,
of course, are going to be
the most tested, you're going
to have much more evaluation
opportunity at a physical site
than if you're out
in the community.
And also it's much
harder to design, right,
if you don't know how many
people are going to show up,
you don't know what
ages they are,
you don't know what their
reading level is going to be.
And so, we've been
exploring this now
for the last three years really
trying to kind of think through,
how do we work with our library
partners to think about outreach
and I use that word
acknowledging
that it can be defined in
so many different ways.
We had-- One of our library
partners said, you know,
outreach is meaning less in
some ways because so much
of the work we have to do is--
has to be embedded in the
community to begin with, right?
What we found was
that one of the best,
best places to do this
work was in laundromats.
And so laundromats are
really interesting spaces
because you have
to go every week
if you don't have a washer dryer
at home, and you were there
for 90 minutes on average.
In the winter if it's--
if you're in a cold place,
you're going more than
once a week especially
if you have many kids.
The more layers, the more
laundry you have to wash.
And what's been interesting,
there's been no day
of the last two years
that I haven't said
the word laundromat.
And so, I've been learning
a lot about the industry,
it's a growing industry which
I think is really interesting
for those of us who
aren't in that space.
The revenues and profits of
laundromats has been going up,
I think as a consequence
of rising poverty.
What you see in this
basis is really, you know,
sometimes if you run a
college campus, of course,
you get college students but for
the most part you're really--
the clients of the
laundromat are lowest income,
can't save the capital $500 to
have a washer dryer at home,
live in space that is too
small, right, or in a building
that doesn't have
those amenities.
And so, over the last year what
we've been doing is partnering
with our local library branches
state county and city libraries
as well as most excitingly a
trade group called the Coin
Laundry Association
and they have
over 30,000 small business
members across the country.
And we're trying to turn now
all 30,000 of those member sites
into extensions of
their local library.
What I love about this is
that we're trying to think
through how to build out these
public private partnerships
at the really hyperlocal
level, right?
Because when you really
think about it, I don't think
that the innovation behind
this is a product, right?
As we've been exploring this,
we found that Chicago Public
Library has been doing
laundromat programs
for the last 20 years.
And so, we brought over
15 other organizations
that have been doing this siloed
laundromat programs together
to meet in Chicago with the
Coin Laundry Association,
to build up the tools
and capacity building
for any other organization that
wants to do this themselves.
I think that the reason why we
want to focus on that rather
than as Libraries
Without Borders,
built at our own
laundromat sites
and operate them is pretty
obvious to me, which is that,
you know, I myself won't know
the contexts, what texts curate,
what challenges people
are facing as well
as our local partners.
And what's dynamic about these
hyperlocal public-private
partnerships between the small
business really Mom-and-Pop Shop
and not even necessarily
a library system
but a library branch is that
they can be super, super dynamic
with changing needs, right?
So when new questions come
up, you change the content.
Last month a lot of the
library systems found
that people were asking a
lot of the tax questions
and so we're trying
to teach literacy
through helping people sort
through those, those questions.
A lot of that is local.
When-- I spoke with one
parent, one mother in one
of the laundromat sites
in Detroit that we have
and this is getting to a more
macro level question that I have
for this group which is, you
know, we've had this prompt
of talking about what programs
work, what programs don't.
How do we define success
in our case, right?
Because literacy rates are
certainly one quantitative way
to measure it but
I'd like to get
at something that's little
bit more emotional and social
and how do we define that.
So when I was in Detroit,
spoke with one parent
who is participating regularly
in the laundromat
literacy programs.
And she said, you know,
her story was she had--
she was a single mom, had just
moved to Detroit, she had moved
with her boyfriend at that time.
He had left her.
She didn't know anyone
else in Detroit.
She'd been there now for a year.
And this was-- she
said the first time
that anyone had spoken to her
and ask her how she was doing?
And it really stuck with
me because I think one
of the main barriers that I
think a lot of people have
with accessing existing
resources, right, is the social
and emotional; barrier.
If you don't have the social
networks that are opening you
to these opportunities,
if you don't have--
if you don't think that
that's basis for you,
it doesn't matter how well
we design the program inside
if people don't feel
like they can use it.
And so, how can we-- as a
community focusing on literacy,
think about not only
generating good content
and making it available but also
think about how we can think
about the softer elements to
make them actually accessible.
One other finding that
we've had is thinking
about how we curate content.
And this gets back to
why I think this sort
of hyper local public-private
partnership is really exciting.
I think that there's
a big difference
between comprehensive
information
and relevant information.
And so, in the laundromats
where we've been putting-- not--
yes, not only a bookshelf
but also what we've
been doing is putting--
moving one of the
folding stations out,
putting for laptops
or desktop computers
with the curated Wi-Fi hotspot.
I think there's a big difference
between providing open access
to internet and curating
the space
to be a really education
focused, literacy focused corner
of the laundromat where
Wi-Fi is really curated
around our content partners,
PBS KIDS, Too Small to Fail,
really thinking about how
we curate that content
so that it's timed between
wash and dry cycles.
Thinking about how we can have
this generational conversation
happening in that space
and answering people's
most urgent questions.
So what we've been
finding is instead
of having this set curriculum
and this again gets to really,
really tough challenge
on evaluation,
instead of answering--
providing, you know,
this is the curriculum
for the laundromat,
what we've been doing is
convening local organizations
to activate the laundromat
as a community anchor, right?
A community center of sorts
during the laundromat's busiest
hours and for those of
you that haven't been
to a laundromat recently, some
of them can have 200 washers,
200 dryers on the weekends.
You have over 300
families at any given time
that you can be working with.
And so the demand is-- it's so
much greater than the supply
when we bring our
librarians there.
But thinking through, you know,
people that we've been having
these conversations with
and running this program with
have something very urgent
that they need to that day.
How can we make sure that the
literacy curriculum especially--
and the digital literacy
curriculum
that we're providing is taught
experientially to answer
that question, right, how do
you not just to use literacy
to read a fiction book
but how do you use it
to find health information,
sign up for health insurance,
figure out how to do your taxes
and learn all those other skills
which I think literacy is the
only way you open the door
to those opportunities for.
And so, I would like
to end on a couple,
just final closing
thoughts which, you know,
again it's not rocket science,
this have been tried and tested
and explained by others but what
we're finding as we're trying
to work on this piece
of the supply chain
of knowledge is really
been on our mind is
that the availability
of programs
and content does not necessarily
mean that it's accessible
and that comprehensive libraries
are not necessarily relevant.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Benita Somerfield: Thank
you so much, Allister.
I think you can see
why he won the award.
OK. Our final panelist
is Rachel Walker.
And her background
is very different.
She's work with Reading Rockets
which is a public television
which we call it
reading program,
reading awareness program.
Everybody wins a whole bunch
of programs of that ilk.
Again, out of the box-- a
bit and Rachel, I think,
[inaudible] representing
one organization.
She'll speak for her
broad experience.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Walker:
Yeah, I represent a lot
of different folks, which
has been exciting for me
over the 30 years in my
career in children's literacy.
I'm here today really
representing Reading Rockets,
which is a national
project of WETA,
the flagship public
television station here
in our nation's capital which
you may know for PBS news hour,
Ken Burns documentaries but
WETA really about 15 years ago,
I had this idea that it would
be a good idea to take advantage
of this internet thing and to
use that to disseminate some
of the best reading research
that's out there because we know
that educators and parents
want that information.
And so, we started
with, you know,
what the National
Institute of Child Health
and Human Development and the
National Reading Panel were
working on to really
determine what is the best
in teaching reading.
And we took that information
and what we know best
which is the power
of story telling
through public television and
turn it into something to try
to really demystify
the reading research
because that's really important.
Teaching reading is complex
and it needs to be responsive
to the needs of each child so
we're not doing the PowerPoint.
No? That's all right.
I can talk without pictures.
No? OK. So what I wanted to
say in terms of why I feel
like Reading Rockets is such
an important reading promotion
partner in the literacy
community is that we need
to remember that we've
got to speak to that,
that reading instruction
is important.
High quality reading instruction
break down those barriers
so that you are ready
to read, to learn.
Sometimes I feel like
that's kind of obvious
that it doesn't get mentioned
but we really do need
to remember that we have kids
who aren't going
to love reading.
And one of the reasons that
they might not love reading
or might avoid reading is
because they haven't
mastered it,
they haven't mastered
decoding to become fluent,
they haven't gotten interested
in learning new words or looking
at new ideas and they're
really frustrated.
So reading promotion helps kind
of create those entry points
for those kids who are learning
or those kids who are striving.
We have to look at
ability and inclination.
So one of the projects
that I've been involved
in through Reading
Rockets but also just
because I'm really interested in
reading and getting kids excited
about reading was when
I was actually working
with Ms. Lynda Johnson Robb,
Reading is Fundamental.
I started partnering with the
National Education Association
when they launched to
Read Across America.
Who knows what Read
Across America is?
Yes. Who knows who wrote,
"You're never too old,
too wacky, too wild, to pick up
a book and read with a child"?
Who-- so say it, who wrote it?
>> [Simultaneously] Dr. Seuss.
>> Rachel Walker: Dr.
Seuss did not write that.
I'm so sorry to tell you
that, that was written
by an NEA staff person
and you can see it all
over the internet credited to
Dr. Seuss but no that belongs
to Anita Merina who
authored that little rhyme.
And it was the rhyme that
any-- I was attracted to,
by Dr. Seuss and, of
course ,the hat, you know,
as Benita was saying with the
Get Caught Reading campaign.
It's that oddness, that
juxtaposition of, you know,
a Supreme Court Justice wearing
a cat in a hat hat is going
to get your attention
and makes you think,
oh maybe this is something that
I should be paying attention to.
But NEA really felt like Dr.
Seuss epitomized, you know,
a love of children
and a love of learning
and this fun fantastical
rhyme and looking in the,
the book that we have the
report from Scholastic.
You see, Dr. Seuss
is all over that.
So he's dear to many folks.
And that's great
and it really has--
for 20 years Read Across America
has generated participation
annually from about
45 million adults
and kids reading together, which
is tremendous, it's on the map.
So that's great,
that's been working.
We've gotten kids
excited about reading and
yet it was time to change.
NEA really recognized
that change was needed.
It was the hat that was starting
to get all the attention.
It wasn't what kids needed
or what adults wanted to do
in their interactions with kids.
So, NEA really took the
opportunity to say we need
to do more, we need to do more
than a one day celebration
on Dr. Seuss's birthday.
We need to launch readers
year round and we need
to give them access to both
those windows and mirrors
and have for the past
several years really place
to greater emphasis
on year round literacy
with an annual calendar and
annual resources that focus
on building a nation
of diverse readers.
So looking at books
by Native Americans,
by folks from all walks of life
to kind of get the story out
and hopefully what that's going
to do is encourage
more diversity,
encourage more diversity
in publishing
and encourage more
diversity in kids reading.
The other hat that I've
been wearing lately is
as a program director
for a nonprofit here
in DC called Everybody Wins.
And Everybody Wins was started
about 25 years ago here in DC
by folks, right over here on
Capitol Hill, Senator Kennedy,
Senator Jeffords realized
that right in the shadow
of the capitol, folks
were not learning to read,
kids were not being read
to, they didn't have access
to books, their school library
was blocked, so they decided one
of the things that
they could do was go
over during their lunch
hour and read to kids.
And we found that that worked
that having a kid and a book
and an adult and a book share
and spend time together
actually made a difference.
Everybody Wins in DC now
serves about a thousand kids
with readers from all over the
city, from all walks of life
and we make sure that
kids are taking books home
so that we're improving their
access to books at home.
But what's really key are those
shared reading experiences
and they're building connections
that are lasting a lifetime.
I recently met a young
man who called to say,
that 20 years ago he
had been a student
at Thompson Elementary
School in DC and he wanted
to know how could he now
become a reading mentor
because his reading mentor
had meant so much to him.
his reading mentor had worked
in the automobile industry.
And guess what this young man
does now, he works as a lobbyist
for the National Automobile
Manufacturing Association.
So this mentor had an impact
that has influenced his life,
influenced his career path and
now he was ready to give back.
So bringing this-- this shared
reading experiences that build
that kind of confidence
that build that kind
of background knowledge
and strengthen those
socioemotional skills
that we all want kids
to have is so critical.
But there's so much more
that we felt like we could do
through the shared
reading experiences
and the opportunities
to engage kids.
One of our-- One of Everybody
Wins additional partnerships
in the city focuses on
bringing authors to schools
with the partnership with
An Open Book Foundation,
which is a nonprofit here in DC
that takes advantage of the fact
that DC is full of authors
and that authors come
to DC all the time.
And so, why not take them to
schools that are underresourced
and might really benefit
from that opportunity.
We're ready now, this is our
innovation, we're ready to take
that step forward and not
just have authors come
into the schools, you know,
here's an author, yay,
here's a book, yay, I got a new
book and the author signed it.
But to move that forward so that
we're continuing the learning
after the experience so that
kids are doing their own
writing, so that kids
are doing more research
on what they've learned and
talked about with the author.
And we're very excited to see
what's going to happen with that
and how we can further
engage the school community
in those opportunities
by involving parents,
by involving parents, by
involving our reading mentors
so that they are also getting
a chance to come and speak
and talk about what
it is they do
and what it is they are
excited about reading
because it's an excited
adult reader
that is an excellent
example for a kid.
And seeing adults around
them choosing reading
and choosing reading as a
fun activity is I don't how
as we can replace that and
I think that's why Read
Across America was-- is so
successful for so many years
because if an adult in your life
is willing to put on a crazy hat
and spend time reading with you,
then you know there's
something to that.
And I'm hoping that
we'll be able to continue
to find exciting entry
points like that for folks
from all walks of life and that
we'll all be working together
on this reading promotion
opportunities
because it makes more
sense if we're all sharing
that information and all kind
of supporting each other
as we do this work.
I love-- I love Reach
Out and Read.
I'm so glad that you mentioned
that Benita because I think
that that's one of the strongest
reading promotion programs
that's out there.
And they need help and everyone
needs help and we're doing a lot
of the things that we all know
are right but we can learn
from each other and
I really appreciate
that we're given the opportunity
to talk to each other and talk
about our mistakes because those
are the things we want to avoid.
Thank you all so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Benita Somerfileld:
Thank you Rachel
for sharing your very
creative ideas from those--
from your work with those very
creative organizations again
out of the box.
Now, Guy, should we open
the floor to questions
and then John, would you like
to also-- so it's 11 o'clock,
we have until 11:45,
so we'll take--
[ Inaudible ]
And let them come
up also afterwards.
OK. Questions?
>> Laura Bailet: Hi.
Laura Bailet.
I'm one of the literacy
advisory board members.
This has been really great
already this morning.
So a couple of questions.
Allister, I'm thinking
about the laundromat issue
which I absolutely love and
but I'm also thinking about--
I'm sorry I'm forgetting
your name--
the woman from the
Enoch Pratt Library.
OK. And you're really important
point that just creating sort
of passage centers
doesn't work very well.
So in the laundromat scenarios,
is there a staff person there
that is guiding or prompting
or teaching or doing something
so that it is an
active learning center?
So if you could maybe
comment on that both
of you if you have that.
>> Allister Chang: So for us,
we've also started to learn more
and more about that
the challenges
of just having a space.
So we found that, you know, like
One Laptop per Child and a lot
of the programs that existed
in international development
that we've tried to learn
from just putting the tools
into place doesn't
necessarily lead
to the educational impact
that we want to see.
It might lead to some
other things, connectivity,
digital access, right.
What we've been doing is
playing around with different--
for different contexts,
different levels of nudges
where if you sign on to
the WiFi that we provide
at the laundromat like at the
airport, you get a portal pops
up on your personal
device brings you straight
to PBS KIDS, right?
WQED or something of this
sort with a kind of caption
that says, you know,
here's a 15-minute activity
that you can do with your child
while you're at the Laundromat,
very kind of, very,
very clearly laid out.
So there's the nudges.
And then I think there's
the restrictions, right?
If you block every site except
PBS KIDS at that Laundromat,
there's that piece too.
And so, we've been
playing around with
that because it's something
that we'd like to test
for with different
content partners.
There's the content
curation piece
but then the main
impact is really coming
from the facilitators, right?
When we have the
librarians actually
on site leading programs
with that those tools is
when we see the highest
engagement, the challenge,
of course, again
is HR is the most--
usually the most expensive and
lowest supply and resource.
And so for us it's
really thinking
through how can the technology
amplify what they're already
doing and extend the reach
of who they can work with.
But at this point we are still
even with those technologies,
even with those nudges mostly
working on convening, right?
Convening facilitators to
come coalesce and volun--
other volunteer groups to come
and actually lead workshops
at the laundromat sites.
>> Deborah Taylor: But
then, I was going to say
that passive displays
sometimes can't work
but for our purposes we try
to be parent, so there were
so many reasons why
it didn't work.
If you could imagine some school
libraries are on the second
or third floor of an
elementary school,
not too many parents
get up to this--
>> You should go there because
people can't [inaudible].
>> Usually people can't hear me
when they shouldn't
be but anyway.
[Inaudible].
I am a librarian and I use to
book talk the middle school
so I'm sure I can project.
The-- You know, many
schools, the school structure,
the physical layout
of the school can sometimes
be a barrier to putting
up a display for parents.
Those libraries with--
library was across the hall
from the office, they got
more parental attention.
So it really did depend
on things like that.
So what we have been able
to do is we've been able
to hire an outreach,
a program assistant
who was outreach specialist in
pre-K through grade 5 outreach
for our schools, so that
we can do some more work
around parental engagement and
connecting those parents back
to both the school library
and the public library,
so that we're kind
of working together
and reinforcing that idea.
But it just happen to be that
that particularly exhibit
or display depending on the
layout of the school was going
to have varying degrees
of success.
>> I have a question too.
So I was so fortunate
to be able to go
to the LaundryCares
Foundation meeting
and as a representative of--
actually being on the board
of Libraries Without Borders.
But Allister if-- can
you tell us what happens
at the largest laundromat
in the world?
>> Benita Somerfield: You
have to do the podium only--
it's not that you don't
project [inaudible], it's--
the people can't
see [inaudible].
>> Pardon.
One of the chores we took
as part of that meeting was
to the largest laundromat
in the world.
>> Allister Chang: Right.
So that-- This is
outside of Chicago.
They have over 300
washers, 300 dryers,
they have an aviary bird center
so the families can
watch the birds.
They have a clown
who's hired part-time
to come every afternoon
and weekends.
[ Inaudible ]
Yup. The owner does pizza every
two times a week every evening
and it is really
already, you know--
I think the partnership
between laundromats
and libraries is
really interesting
because already laundromats are
in some ways community
anchors, right?
And so the fit is really easy
to find the connections with.
Thanks for sharing that word.
>> Benita Somerfield: Thank you.
Other questions?
>> So I have a related question.
This laundromat thing
is fascinating.
So I'm interested in hearing--
I'm taking Laura's question
a little bit further.
Is the outreach-- and I
understand you define that kind
of liberally but is that meant
to say within the laundromat
and is it a space construction?
Is there some kind of hope to
convert to Library cards or move
to a Library for a
different kind of programming?
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
Thank you.
>> Allister Chang: So we've
been doing free laundry days
with sponsorship.
It's a great way to build new
sponsorships with corporations
that haven't funded
libraries in the past.
Four hours free laundry, laundry
is 5, $10 a-- $5 a load usually,
so it's-- it adds
up for families.
One connection that I found
that's really interesting is a
lot of the kids say-- have said
that they are embarrassed to go
to school if their
laundry is not clean
so there's other dignity
elements to it too.
Well with free laundry what we
do is partner with a laundromat,
provide free laundry for four
hours we usually have three,
four hour line outside
the block.
Invite local organizations
to come.
Sign people up for their
programs and sign people up,
in order to get free laundry,
you have to have a
library card, right?
And that's an easy another
nudge restriction that we put
on which I know is not the most.
It's a little bit of the
eager piece but I think
if we have a clown there it's
kind of-- it's fun [laughter].
>> So my question is to Dr. Roy
but really could be
answered by anyone.
I still appreciated or
comments about being careful
that we're not colonizing that
when we're trying to partner
with organizations
and communities
that we're not bringing
our own values.
And I see the challenge of that
is that we're bringing support
to a community because we
believe that we have solutions
that can support that community
but if we're not really partners
in listening and apart of that,
we very much are just placing
our values on top of them.
So really appreciate of that.
And I'm just wondering what has
worked or not worked in for you
or for anyone else in making
community partnerships
that really truly partner
with the community?
>> Loreiene Roy: Great.
That's a great question.
I guess I'll use an example.
Some years ago, the
State Library
in Arizona had a
supplemental grant
to their Bill & Melinda Gates
funded technology centers.
And so they provided
some funding
to a higher community
tech in six
or eight tribal settings
in Arizona.
Hopi Reservation, there
was one on-- let's see--
I think Tony Odom
[assumed spelling], there--
so different locations,
travel locations.
And I was the evaluator
for the project.
And each site also
had a student intern
from the University of Arizona.
And so I got to meet with
all of the technology people,
all the community people.
I remember going to a
chapter house on Navajo
and Navajo woman, then a woman
sat next to me very quietly
and then pushed something toward
me, and it was a huge notebook,
and it was filled with all
of the things she had
learned to do at that center.
And she had started for
the first time her own way
of earning money was to
produce a graduation cards.
And she learned Photoshop
and she learned how to print.
And she didn't say a word
but she showed me everything.
And so I got to hear what
patrons did at those sites.
But speaking with the students,
I also got to learn a little bit
about the motivation,
more about the motivation
of why did they volunteer
to go and work
in support a community
tech person from
and their own travel community
and that students
were nonnative.
Anyway the first student who
want to speak to me, she said,
I need 20 minutes of the hour.
And what she talked about is
what she felt she should have
experienced but didn't.
She says, I should
have been brought
into the sacred religious
experiences I want--
and her demands were great.
And I had already spoken to
the people of those sites,
so I kind of had a heads
up of what the students
are going to say.
And I said, so why
did you want this?
And she says, well, my dad
was an Indian house service
physician in 20 years ago.
That was his experience.
And then another
young student said--
and then they, they
had complaints.
They said, you know, I showed
up on the day I was supposed
to be there and nothing
happened.
No one knew I was coming.
And at-- so that was
a common experience.
But I knew one of the
students had been a star.
And that they-- they
didn't know.
I'd already heard
from their sites.
And we got to this
student and I said,
so what was your experience?
She says, oh, like
everyone else.
I went on the day I was supposed
to and no one was there,
she said, but I went
the next day.
And she said, then I
went the following week.
And what she did was her
expectations were she was there
to help.
And she was not there to
gain some inside track.
So, a part was the motivation.
I think that many gifts come
from being involved
in community level.
But it's not something you
can say, I'm going to do this,
so I'm going to cherry pick
some cultural experience
so I can talk about
it in 20 more years.
So, you know, I have--
one of the books I've
read in there is a chapter
on examining one's motivation
and everyone needs
to do that as well.
So does that help answer
the question a little bit?
OK. Thanks.
>> Benita Somerfield: As you
can see we've opened the floor
to everybody, the first
panel and the second panel.
OK. Other questions?
None? Yes sir?
>> This is a question
for anybody,
but maybe Allister
would be the best or--
you know, I come mostly from
an international background.
When you travel around the
world you hear ministers
and librarians say-- talk
about a reading culture.
So even in the golf for example,
they are burrowed with people
who are quite wealthy.
So we don't really have a
reading culture whereas we go
to Russia for example, even the
relatively poor people are--
they're great readers.
Is there anything in this
idea of a reading culture
or is it just as Dr. Krashen
said, you know, if you're poor,
you don't read and if you're
not poor, you read more.
Or, is there a body
research on that
and is it relevant
to the United States?
>> Stephen Krashen: I think
it's unfair to ask question
because so many people do
not have access to books.
>> Benita Somerfield: Could
you come to the podium?
>> Stephen Krashen: This
is good for my career.
Wonderful.
If they have access to books
and they're still not reading,
we can talk about the
absence of reading culture.
But as James Patterson, which
I just quoted and pointed out,
it may very well be the case
that nonreaders are simply those
who haven't found
the right books yet.
Great study.
I would like to see replicated
in the laundromat was called
"Spiderman in the Library."
I forgot the author's name.
They put comic books
in the library
for junior high school children,
did not allow them to circulate,
they had to go to the
library to read the comic.
Library traffic went up doubled.
Books taken out went up
30% in a very short time.
When we bring in
books, they really,
really, really want to read.
And the best thing out now
for young people, comic books
and graphic novels, no question.
One of the great things
about being on the airplane,
you get to catch up
on the marvel movies.
Oh my gosh.
Wonder Woman, Black Panther,
serious philosophical
discussions.
Wonder Woman is about
the nature of evil.
I'm going to spoil it for you.
Black Panther is on
the nature of justice.
How do we do this?
Is it correct when you
are born into wealth,
when you're given it,
what is your obligation?
OK. These are heavy things
and that's what people--
it's framed in such a brilliant
way that people get involved
in literature and reading.
So, let's ask the
question when we've--
about reading cultures when
we solve the access problem.
Great question.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Deborah Taylor: That's
really an important question
because I remember
hearing that commercial,
read to your child
15 minutes a day,
and I used to think
nobody ever read to me.
But my grandmother
was a storyteller.
And so it's not so much
just the culture of reading,
is it a culture of storytelling?
And how do you incorporate
that so those stories are
captured and passed down?
So one of the things that we do
with family reading circles is
when we close out-- sometimes
we have a visiting illustrator,
sometimes we have
a visiting author.
But sometimes we have
a visiting storyteller.
Because one of the
things that we--
that if you observe
how parents interact
with their children now,
they are always giving
them directions.
They are seldom really
telling them things
or storytelling anymore.
My grandmother told me
stories constantly whenever we
were together.
So I think the culture
of storytelling is the one
we want to really encourage.
And if it means writing down
those stories and capturing them
and sharing them,
then that, I think,
helps with the whole
prospect of a reading culture.
>> Benita Somerfield: Thank you.
>> Stephen Krashen: Can I
add a friendly amendment?
>> Benita Somerfield: What?
>> Stephen Krashen: A
friendly short amendment
to your wonderful comment?
We-- Stories are what
makes the world go round.
All-- Everybody like
stories constantly.
Let me give you some
advice for your social life.
If you're invited to a party
and you don't know anybody,
watch three lady's movies.
You can always go up to someone
and say, I just saw, you know,
Iron Man 26, you
know, or whatever.
And, you know, Iron
Ladies, Iron Lady,
and you can get a
reasonable conversation going
because people want
to know about stories.
We interpret our
lives as a narrative
where we are the protagonists.
So, absolutely.
>> Thanks for that.
>> Thank you.
>> Rachel Walker: I think
it is an important addition,
but one of the things that has
worried me about when we talk
about creating a culture
around reading is I've asked
so many people over the
years, are you a reader?
Do you consider yourself
a reader?
Do you like reading?
And most of the time,
the answer I get is no.
I don't like reading.
I don't like reading at all.
And then I said,
but do you read?
What do you read?
Oh yeah, I read all the time.
I read newspapers.
I read this.
I read journals.
I read-- they don't
read fiction.
So I don't want to-- I totally
agree about storytelling
but my concern is
is that we've--
read to your child 15 minutes
a day, gives you that image
of I'm sharing a Dr.
Seuss book with you
or I'm sharing a story with you.
And I don't want to leave
out those folks who come
at it in a different way.
>> Stephen Krashen: There is
research, there's research
on gossip and stories.
Most of what goes on in
newspapers is human interest.
What Albert Einstein
talked to other physicists,
they talked about their personal
lives, stories and gossip.
I still maintain stories as
what makes the world go round.
>> Lesley Farmer: And then
just to even broaden it more,
I think you can also
talk about song.
So just recently words on
literature where, you know,
Bob Dylan won earlier,
you know, Ira Gershwin.
So, again, these are gateways,
storytelling, the songs,
the rhythms that we have are
all gateways to literacy.
>> Deborah Taylor: I've heard
parents say that their children
or there's-- particularly,
this occurs with boys,
that all he wants to
do is study baseball
or basketball statistics.
And I tell them, he is creating
the narrative in his head
from those statistics.
He is a reader.
But he is going after his
story land, his narrative
in a different way than
I might who, you know,
with a voracious reader
of trashy romance novels.
So it just really does--
you know, you really have
to respect the reader
where the reader is.
And then I think
people see themselves
as part of that culture.
>> Lois Bridges: Yeah.
Just speaking to the scholarly
culture, I just wanted
to mention one of the most
significant studies of all
at the University of
Nevada, Mariah Evans,
who's a sociologist, found
that even just 12 books
in the home created what she
called a scholarly culture.
And I think what she meant
is that if you have books
in the home, you're
talking about the books,
you're reading the books.
You're sharing the
books with each other.
And we find that parents who may
not have had access to literacy
as children themselves, if their
children are bringing books
home, then they're
learning to read.
The children, you have the books
in the home, are reading allowed
to their younger siblings.
So you've-- it's-- the
talk as everyone has seen
around the books, that is
so critically important.
And also, by the
way reading allowed
to children is so important.
We know, but again, it's the
talk about the read allowed,
you know, that bringing out
the child's personal engagement
with the book that
really makes a difference.
So, in the end, it all comes
back again to access to books.
If you have access to
books, anything is possible.
>> Loreiene Roy: I'll just
add a couple of things.
When we run--
>> Benita Somerfield:
In the podium.
>> Loreiene Roy: OK.
When we run the reading
club for native kids,
I would go to travel schools and
we would certainly read books
but we always did
the storytelling too.
And I know that that the
secret to getting native kids
to pay attention is
to say you're going
to tell them a ghost story.
And you then tell
them ghost stories
that you yourself experienced
and they're really true.
And then I always told
the true ghost stories.
And-- But for native kids,
one difference would be that--
just like storytelling
is social,
reading is very social
for native children.
And board books, you think
of board books as a bit--
books that you give babies,
but we found that kids
up to fourth grade would
use the board books
because they would sit
with other children especially
younger ones and they would go
through the books together.
And they would form their
own little pads of reading.
They knew especially in those
schools where kid had reading--
kids had reading level to know
that they knew everybody's
reading level
and they would help each
other select the books.
Like oh, no, no, no.
You want to read this,
you want to read that.
So reading as a culture
is very communal just
like storytelling is communal
with native schools especially.
>> Benita Somerfield:
I just have one comment
I'd like to make.
I need to speak up for the
adults, which is nobody is.
What we found in the
Barbara Bush Foundation,
we funded about a thousand
programs over the years.
Many parents who were not
interested in investing
in themselves for variety
of reasons mostly none
of them very good about
self-concept care to learn
to read so they could
read to their children.
I agree with you, it's the
conversation that matters,
but I really-- I worked
in programs before I've
run a foundation, you know,
during the great society
stuff in prisoners
and in homeless shelters
and whatever.
I don't-- we did family
literacy programs in prisons.
I don't think it's
going to sound crazy.
I don't think I ever run into
a parent that didn't want
to be able to learn to read, to
read a book to his or her child.
And reading in this context
doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to have
fantastically developed
reading skills.
It's be with the child, turn
the pages, tell the story.
And that often insights a desire
to learn to read on the part
of the adults because it's for
the relationship with the child.
I just throw that in.
Sorry, go ahead.
>> Hi. So my office,
we do museum education.
And so I'm listening to all of
you and we're probably not going
to get books into
children's hands as much,
we're doing more
digital outreach.
Is there-- Can you recommend,
do you have, just off the top
of your head, maybe strategies
for what we should be creating
or how maybe should we be
reaching out to parents,
should we be reaching
out to libraries?
What's our best approach
to help kids?
>> Loreiene Roy: I'll just use
one example since this is just
down the street the National
Museum American Indian.
So I was involved with a group
that created the first online
exhibits for the museum working
with eight, nine
and 10-year-olds.
And so, my job was to help
the children narrate a tour
of the museum materials
on exhibit that we move
from exhibition cases.
We created 360 movies
of the objects,
linked them to panoramic
views of the exhibit space.
And then the kids narrated
the tour but we use
that following a narrow
history model of asking.
I asked the children to
describe who created the object,
where were they from,
how did they created
and for what purpose.
And they used written
materials as well
as their own cultural stories
to do the interpretation.
So that was for the NMAI.
>> Benita Somerfield:
Any other responses?
>> Rachel Walker: So with
PBS and Reading Rockets,
we are definitely
a digital platform.
And so, we've done a lot at
looking at what that means
and how is that really useful.
And we found that one of
the things that is great is,
of course, video because
videos are very accessible.
You can tell a lot of
stories with video.
But also we found that it
works even better if you take
that video and you put it into
action so that if it's a digital
and you're communicating with
folks all over the world,
they can learn how
to use that video
to the best that it can be used.
So they share it with a
parent or to use it as part
of the professional development
opportunity for a teacher.
So it can't just-- we don't
want it to just be static
and they're online, we know
people will find it and use it
but to have that kind of
outreach in those opportunities
where you're saying, here
are a lot of different ways
that you can put it into
action in your community.
>> Benita Somerfield:
Any other responses?
OK. Next question.
>> Hi. Well, I'm really
interested in Rachel
and what you were
saying and you all--
some of you all have alluded to
this with the power of process
and children going from author
visits or a books experience
and making their own narrative
and what that looks like.
So I just wanted to know if you
could talk a little bit more
about that that process.
>> Benita Somerfield: You go.
>> Rachel Walker: So
one of the reasons
that I was really excited about
working with Everybody Wins
and the idea of doing
more to engage kids
to share reading experiences
that were not necessarily
just one-on-one but looking
at that kind of community
that you build
when you're sharing a
book that's the same
and sharing the experience of
getting to meet the author.
For a couple of years, I spent
some time in a middle school
and we decided that we
really needed to focus
on helping students figure
out what motivated them
as readers and writers.
And we thought that one
thing that would really do
that would be to introduce
them to a lot of writers.
And, yes, it was actually
true that that work.
So one year we had I think 14
author visits during a school
year which was a tremendous
amount of effort on part
of the teachers and
the librarians there.
But what we saw was that
kids were and we ask them
because we wanted to make sure.
So we-- first we wanted to
know who do you want to meet,
what authors are you interested
in, or what are your interests
because it wasn't going to do
any good to bring an author
that we hadn't prep the kids
for or that didn't have some
of connection to what
they are already learning
or working on in school.
So to make it really
concentrated effort on figuring
out how it fits in
to their daily lives
because it's not
just necessarily
that they're interested that's
going to be the motivation
for them to get excited about
this but it's going to be kind
of what they're existing
background knowledge is,
so that they can take
it and go with it.
So that's really what we look
at, the motivation factor
but then also what
it is that we're--
that they already have
that we can build on.
And it-- I'm hoping
that it's going to work
in elementary schools too.
>> Deborah Taylor: The
Pratt library partnered
with the Reginald Lewis Museum
and the Baltimore
City public schools
to run a book making
contest that we had funded
from the Ezra Jack
Keats Foundation.
They run the huge
one in New York.
And so we were just starting out
and this gave the students a
chance to write their stories
to illustrate their stories.
We did a teacher workshop,
so the teachers learned how
to show them different ways
of making the books
like anything else.
We had one teacher that
caught fire with the idea.
And she was teaching
graphics art, ends with this--
all of these submissions from
her class and they worked
on getting those
students to actually write
and make graphic novels
from what they did.
And then we have the
announcement of the winners
at the Reginald Lewis Museum
and then the library
displayed the winning and some
of the other submission.
So the three of us, there
were some kind of way
that they're all three
institutions were engaged.
>> Rachel Walker: And
I love the book making.
One of the other things
that we did was we figured
that kids were so excited
about what they were learning
from authors that
they wanted to share
that with all of
their classmates.
So we created a podcast
that students then
after the author visits
would interview the authors
and then develop their
own podcast to share
that information with other
schools, other students,
other communities,
which was a lot of fun.
>> Benita Somerfield: OK.
Other questions?
Laura.
>> Laura Bailet: I've been
thinking a lot recently
about the social
dimension of reading.
And I think that that can
be a really powerful draw
to help foster that culture of
reading that you talked about.
And also encourage people
to read in whatever way
who might not otherwise
be doing that.
Now for myself I love nothing
more than as an individual
and private person curling
up with a good book.
But I'm also-- I also
really enjoy a book club.
And I think that there are
many examples of people,
young and old who are making
reading social that could help
that sort of catch fire.
I think one example that
I saw in the past year
or so was a little boy,
an 11-year-old boy named
Sydney Keys [assumed spelling]
in the saint Lewis area who
started books and brows.
He's an African-American boy
and he was having
trouble finding books
about people like him.
And he worked with a
private book seller
and now he has this whole
African-American boy's book club
that's going.
And I think what
a fabulous idea.
And so, I wonder if others
have knowledge of qualitative
or quantitative research on the
impact of this social dimension
of reading whether
it's big campaigns
like Oprah Winfrey's book thing.
PBS now has a-- is it a book
of the month or whatever.
So I don't-- I wonder if
others have perspectives
and information on that because
I think that can inject a lot
of fun and social element
that might be a catalyst
for people to read.
>> Benita Somerfield: OK.
>> Allister Chang: This is not
directly in the literacy space
but we've been partnering
with MIT media labs Peer 2 Peer
University and thinking a lot
about how to turn
MOOCs into, you know,
raise the retention
rates of MOOCs.
It's relied-- really
most robust studies
on raising retention ever lied
on creating these pure networks.
And I think that would tie
closely to reading as well.
>> And that was fast.
>> Lesley Farmer: So a lot of
you know about the Harry Potter
and what kind of group
of book clubs, you know.
And part of their work which
is now, you know, international
and they have, you
know, local chapters.
So you build in the
local social aspect
as well as between chapters.
And every year one of the
requirements, you know,
for a chapter and these are
all free, is to gather books
and then distribute them to,
you know, folks in need for it.
So that's part of their deal.
And they also collaborate, you
know, with local publishers
in terms of making
books available online.
So that social thing really,
you know, fosters, you know,
kind of a growing
network of readers
of literacy and friendship.
>> Lois Bridges: I know that
Chris certainly knows about this
but I just wanted to
say that in classrooms
where there are robust
independent reading programs,
you find books clubs and
you also find teachers
who know books, love
books, know literature
and every day book talks.
So like a movie trailer
for books advertising
books all the time,
catching kid's attention, we--
you know, we have this idea that
reading this sort of a solo,
lonely sort of thing but
know in the best classrooms
where readers thrive, there's
a rich reading culture and lots
and lots of talk and sharing.
Books catch hold just
like everybody wants to,
you know, wear a certain brand.
Every kid in the classroom
wants to read the latest book
from certainly daycare
rallying was sort
of the ultimately example.
I think more kids became readers
in the pages of Harry Potter
than any other book in history.
But reading is definitely
social.
It's also cultural, of
course, and it's very personal.
>> Laura Bailet: So,
I'm thinking this
should be a project
for our Literacy Awards board.
It's kind of to come up
with some best practices
or do a whole symposium around
making books social to promote
that culture of reading.
I'm very captivated with that.
I think that is a big topic
that deserves more attention.
So thanks.
>> Loreiene Roy: So we have lots
of examples of the one book,
one week type of
activity especially
from Nancy Pearl's
encouragement.
I can think of another example
with teens, native teens.
We organize something with
reader girls a few years ago
and it was operation
team book drop.
So we deliver the free book
to 10,000 native teens.
And feedback from the
teachers involved were--
and this was one of the
few examples they had.
They told us of kids who
no matter where they were
in reading where awarded.
So they were used to getting,
giving books to the kids
who read well but not the kids
who are having difficulty, so.
>> Benita Somerfield: Just to
reinforce your point Laura,
I was in book publishing
for a number of years.
And Oprah Winfrey's book club
was the single biggest seller
of books that anyone
had ever seen.
If you got your book
nominated named by Oprah
as the book, the
sells went crazy.
From that, I believe,
came the book clubs.
All of a sudden my
cousin out in Long Island
who very rarely read, she's
telling me she's going
to a book club rather than
go into a fitness this.
Well, it became something you
were supposed to do, right?
They were all reading
books together
and then people really began
to enjoy though I know people
who make time in tremendously
busy schedules to go
and read the book,
right, make their time.
So there's definitely,
I agree with you,
there's definitely something
social and important in that
that I think what
you're looking to.
Yes.
>> Just thinking about a culture
of literacy and how we get
from here to there and thinking
about this Scholastic statistics
and thinking Jim
Trelease' handbook,
Read-Aloud handbook
and, you know--
and beginning at the beginning
that at birth as close
as we can come to people
reading aloud and having
that shared experience
of love and bonding
around a book, the
better we can be.
And even though the Scholastic
statistic improved from 30
to 40%, that 60% of people
who don't know this yet and so
to think about what if
every baby received a book
that families received
the book when they're born
to welcome them across
our country,
so just planting a seed.
>> Benita Somerfield: Yeah.
>> I just wanted to follow back
on the previous question
about book clubs.
So I think a lot of us are we
actually offer book club kind
of programming.
And one thing that we are trying
to do is find more information
or data to support the fact
that this is really an
important thing to be offering.
So if there is any such data
about this, how important it is
for the social aspect of book
clubs or what else they can do,
it would be really appreciated.
>> Benita Somerfield: OK.
>> Deborah Taylor:
I was going to say--
>> Benita Somerfield:
All right, all right.
>> Deborah Taylor: I think
one of the things that--
especially for young people,
for teens in particular is
the availability of authors
and their willingness to
engage kids in social media.
Most of us if you follow
any of the social media,
many of the authors are
really, really active
and they're engaging
with their readers.
So it's not just about
me reading a book,
it's about me interacting with
the authors, the other people
who like the same
books that I like.
So social media gets a bad wrap
and then well-deserve
one sometimes.
But it also has been a way
that writers can engage
with their readers and also
to have that back and forth.
And so that it does become
more of a social activity.
>Allister Chang: Your
question I think raises
for me a few followups to which
are thinking about what is--
how do we-- if-- how do we
identify the exact intervention
and then how do we--
what are the indicators
that we would actually
evaluate for that, right?
Is it really rising literacy
rates in that community,
is it economic empowerment,
is it more jobs?
I think as we are-- and we look
at why the Gates Foundation
closed their global libraries
program, one of the
things that they told us,
our program officer told us
was they were framing libraries
as both the solution
and the problem, right?
What is the problem?
Not enough libraries.
What is the solution?
Build more libraries.
But more and more were
moving towards a place
where a public policy
priorities,
foundation priorities.
I think individuals
too are thinking more
about what are the tools and
things that I invest my time
and that lead me to a
certain end goal, right?
And I think it is our
task as a community
to communicate how
our interventions
around building those book
clubs ties to those as well.
And I think that that's-- I
would be really interested
for the researchers here
to think about what is it--
what can we do with knowing that
there are so many interventions
around the social aspect of
books to tie that to some
of those priorities, those
public policy priorities
that we can actually get
funding for these programs
to continue existing, right?
>> Benita Somerfield:
I think this--
[ Inaudible ]
OK. Is there another question?
>> I just have a quick question.
I hope it's a quick
answer but if not,
it's something you
might want to consider.
Is there a teen online
book club?
There is? OK.
Is there one that anyone
recommends over another
that we could direct teens?
Because I don't feel like if
there's a space we direct teens
that may-- they may
not want to be there
or they may feel regulated
and that's something
we've been thinking about.
>> Benita Somerfield: Can
anybody answer that one?
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lois Bridges: Good reads?
Have you-- Are you
familiar with that?
And they have, you know,
teen open specifically
geared for younger people.
Are there other ones that
I-- that others know about?
>> There is one--
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lesley Farmer: I think you're
most often able to find those
through the public
libraries when they do,
you know, specific programming.
And one advantage of doing
it locally is then, you know,
kids that know each
other face-to-face,
then they can continue
that because part
of that social deal is
building relationships.
But there are-- all
right, there are Teen Inc.
and so many others have
been around for a long time.
So I don't have it right off
the top of my head but check
with your public library
and they can probably
tell you what are some
of the good ones or ask a team.
>> Benita Somerfield: I
have one other suggestion.
The single best selling category
for book publishers right
now is young adult books.
And I would check individual
publishers of books and deal
with this and their authors and
see if there are book clubs.
I don't know any off the top
of my head but my guess is
that there, very well, might be
book clubs within those websites
because they've gotten much
more active in those areas.
I think that's it.
>> Loreiene Roy: I'll
add one thing to that.
There's a new initiative through
the American Library Association
with a Kellogg grant
on truth racial equity
and transformation.
And these are to setup national
discussions around those topics
with teens across the US with--
starting with some
pilot public libraries.
So they have their
material available as well.
>> Benita Somerfield: Well,
thanks to everyone who're
really stellar panels.
I mean, really.
[ Applause ]
Not just blah, blah,
blah, but concrete stuff.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.